there is growing outrage this morning
over an encounter between a white police
officer and an eight-year-old boy in
syracuse new york who is black a
bystander filmed the officer holding the
child's arms from behind and putting him
in the back of a patrol car now police
say the little boy was being taken home
he was not arrested after allegedly
stealing a bag of potato chips jerika
duncan is following this story
[Music]
to me and this video viewed tens of
thousands of times on social media the
clearly distraught eight-year-old is
seen being held from behind by an
officer detained for allegedly stealing
a bag of chips so what's going on there
he's stealing stuff if he breaks into
your house to steal
moments later the child can be heard
crying as the officer puts him in the
back of his patrol
car bystander kenneth jackson says he
felt compelled to start recording i felt
his terror
and decided to be what are you doing
there's a way that the police need to
interact with kids and what they did is
completely unacceptable the boy's father
says the officers brought his son home
then i saw the video
then i was very mad now a officer
who wear the uniform who supposed to
protect life and property look at how he
might treated my son the syracuse police
department issued a statement saying in
part the juvenile was not placed in
handcuffs officers met with the child's
father and no charges were filed
we need to see the whole incident look
at you know find out what the body worn
cameras show keith taylor is a college
professor and former police officer he
says when all the facts are known the
department should be able to determine
whether the officer should have handled
the situation differently could there be
improvements
well if the policy says that's what
they're supposed to do then you look at
the policy
the mayor of syracuse says the officer
knew the child from prior interactions
police say they are reviewing the body
camera videos from all three officers
involved in this incident i think it's
triggering when you look at the numbers
in terms of how
black and brown children have been
criminalized and you see an
eight-year-old and you ask yourself is
there any other way we could have
handled this so that he didn't have to
be in a police car well it seems like
such a teachable moment that if you had
called the parents to the scene
that there could have been a different
interaction and maybe they attempted
that i mean i think they should do a
thorough review and if there's a better
way to do it better way to handle it
that should be the new practice but once
again it's the cell phone that sort of
shines light on how these things happen
or bring about questions about possible
policies that might have yeah it's hard
when you hear the anguish of the child
who's clearly very shaken up and
probably maybe a little traumatized by
it you do have to wonder is there a
better way because i think
well not everybody but many kids have
stolen stuff from stores you know i
remember stealing a hostess cherry pie
when i was a little little yeah and came
home and said no i hadn't done anything
you have cherry pie all over your face
and i had to go back right right and
gail look go back and apologize yes but
my parents dealt with me yes exactly
there had to be a better way to handle
it yeah the video is tough to watch yeah
very tough to watch because he's a big
officer and such a little kid yeah all
right
thank you very much